a woman who accused a powerful
politician of abuse is speaking out in
her first TV interview Michelle Manning
bearish dated former New York Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman for more than
a year until 2015 she shared her story
with The New Yorker in May saying quote
all of a sudden he just slapped me
open-handed and with great force across
the face she went on to say he began to
choke me Sneiderman resigned three hours
after that story was published and last
week a prosecutor announced that
Schneiderman will not face criminal
charges after multiple women came
forward the Nassau County District
Attorney said in a statement that she
believes the accusers but could not
pursue criminal charges because of quote
legal impediments Schneiderman said in a
statement quote I accept full
responsibility for my conduct in my
relationships with my accusers and for
the impact it had on them Michelle
Manning barish is here in her first
television interview good morning and
thank you for being here good morning
Nora thank you for having me I can only
imagine how hard it was to speak out in
the beginning to describe this abuse
what led you to share what happened to
you well I never was going to share my
story I was never going to talk about it
I didn't even think I had a me to story
to be honest with you until I saw Rob
Porter's wife and she had that black eye
and a White House secretary that's right
uh-huh and then I struggled with feeling
like a hypocrite there were so many
women who were coming out and speaking
and telling their stories and I was
encouraging them to do this and I had a
story and I hadn't said anything but I
decided that I didn't want to ruin my
life
and I wasn't going to say anything and I
just was going to leave it at that until
Jane Mayer from The New Yorker reached
out to me and said we'd like to talk to
you about Eric Schneiderman
and I knew exactly why she was calling
when she told me that there were two
other women who were about to go on
record and they had been hurt and one of
them had sustained hearing loss I you
know my knees just sort of buckled and I
knew that I had three choices you
I could either remain silent or I could
lie or speak up and tell the truth
what's extraordinary about this story
too it's different than the others is
that this powerful rising star in the
Democratic Party who was a champion of
women's rights has also now essentially
admitted that he did something wrong and
he said in a statement after spending
time in a rehab facility I am committed
to a lifelong path of recovery and
making amends to those I have harmed I
apologize for any and all pain that I
have caused has he personally apologized
to you he has not he has not personally
apologized to me and what do you think
of him saying that he accepts
responsibility for his actions well I
appreciate that he has made a blanket
statement with an apology I hope that it
is sincere the reason why I'm here today
is not to drag Eric through the dirt or
to drag this story on me longer than it
needs to go I knew going in that I
wouldn't have personal justice in this
because my statute of limitations was up
I went into it just to support the other
women and to make sure that they had a
stronger case in case they wanted to
pursue it so if he is genuinely sincere
about what he's saying he's still
sitting on he raised 11 mil million
dollars it was we thought it was a 0.5
we actually looked it up my lawyer did
it's over 11 million dollars that he
raised and he spent 2.6 of it so far on
his own expenses so the National
Organization for Women had asked him to
donate the rest of what was left in his
campaign fund to help women across the
state of New York with shelters programs
there's so much that we can do with that
money and he did not respond he's been
asked again and he has not responded so
you want that money to go to causes that
help women who've suffered abuse I do I
do and you know night if we're not
talking about $20,000 here we're talking
about nine million dollars that can
change a lot of lives that can change
the lives of hundreds of thousands of
women it can help men it can help you
know all sorts of people who are
suffering through this and
former attorney general though his
campaign has said that they are honoring
their commitments that they had and that
they are going to donate any remaining
funds to worthy causes
is there any reason to believe that he
won't do this that he won't donate that
money I see that a lot of money has been
spent I'm concerned at how much more of
it is going to be spent and also you
know worthy causes is a pretty general
statement I think that what he did was
he assaulted women he's admitted to this
I was one of them and I think a worthy
cause and a great step towards healing
for all of us is to donate it directly
to where he caused that harm you know
and not just some organization that he
happens to be very fond of you know it's
an important conversation sharing your
story but also trying to find some good
out of this and to help other people who
may have suffered the same thing thank
you so much for joining us thank you
Nora